we'll start the last session of the day
with more the receptions so it's my
pleasure to introduce Brock twice and
he's going to talk to us today about new
bounds on the covering then Steve thank
you very much Dale for introducing me so
well and pronouncing my name correctly
and inviting me to give this lecture to
the other organizers organizers as well
so this is for the past few years it's
been really a pleasure for me to
discover that computer scientists and
election electoral engineers are also
very interested in lattices and have a
lot of great ideas about lattices I've
been studying lattices from a dynamical
point of view for a while but now
there's a lot of things going on that
are bringing people together and so I
hope the program will be a success and
I'm glad to be here I'm also glad I was
I had the stereotyped thing in a
computer science center you're gonna
have to prepare a beamer talk because
all the computer science talks I've been
to we're always kind of very nice
beaming talks unfortunately that's not
the case because I have a white board
talk so my co-authors are mentaly who is
a electrical engineer and then I get for
many of you probably know there's a
computer scientist and what we study is
the so called covering density of the
lattice so let me define that so okay so
tonight I mean it's just a convex set
with non empty interior it doesn't have
to be symmetric and the covering density
L is the lattice
covering density of L with respect to K
which is usually denoted with this
capital theta is the volume of R times K
times K okay so let's read this
carefully if you haven't seen it before
so what we want to do is take our set K
dilate it and such a way that when you
Center it at every lattice point you
cover space and dilated by the smallest
possible amount and we are rescaled
we're measuring things in terms of the
volume so the quantity doesn't really
depend on K just depends on the shape of
K up to up to dilations we are rescaling
in the denominator by the co volume of
the lattice so it's really not a
question about the co volume of the
lattice either it's insensitive to
dilations and of course it's also
insensitive to translations because if k
trance tiles covers and so does any of
its translates that's a geometric
quantity and some of you may be familiar
with the so called covering radius which
is an associated quantity where if
you're talking about say a symmetric
body or you could even ball you want to
take them over the radius of the ball so
this is a kind of a more refined getting
estimates on this is someone worried
fine because this grows much more
rapidly as you increase the dimension as
the radius grows the volume grows by the
radius to the power n so it makes it
possible to look at this in detail but
everything about this quantity can be
translated into a statement and theta
capital theta K and
Monte's so it's more minute if to make
theta small means that we're able to
cover space you can make this quantity
small it means we're able to make find a
lattice for which the overlaps of the
translates of the body k don't take up
too much of the volume of space k where
a cube we could take ZN it would a space
perfectly with no overlaps and this
quantity would be equal to exactly one
one it's an obvious lower bound because
you can't cover space this is sort of
what Noah was explaining in the
beginning of lecture there's no way to
do this more efficiently then this is
the definition of study and Rogers spent
a lot of time studying it
there's a if K is K is a Euclidean ball
in that case Roger
Rogers proved that this quantity is
bounded by we're not being completely
precise Rogers was more precise than I
am but for the acquitting ball the the
covering density is somewhere between
constant times n somewhere between one
constant times n and another constant
times n times a power of the log so it's
quite precise for a general body the
upper bound constants its end to a power
log log and so it's slightly growing
slightly faster than polynomial okay and
so you see that there's a quite a big
gap between what Rogers could prove for
the including ball and this was later
generalized to a few other higher
dimensional analogues of balls for other
norms and other bodies with large
symmetries this value is much much
better than this film so our first
theorem which I'll stay over here
unless is the chief this density are
they easy to describe no the argument
involves a probabilistic component so
they're they're found their existence is
proved probabilistically but the
probability I'll say a few words about
what kind of probability distribution
was used by Rogers in a moment okay
it's not a kind of a common meat study
about our first theorem this statement
and squared so we've improved log log n
to n squared which almost matches what's
known for the Euclidean ball up to the
distinction between N and N squared the
second so let you n so that's really Ln
B the space of all lattices of Co vol.1
this is the space that was mentioned by
Noah I'll just write SL in RSO and Z so
that ll NB this face of lattices
one in un Longy than what knowing is
hard as ego okay so I want to scare our
people who are non mathematician so but
I do want to be precise and so on the
space of all possible lattices there's a
natural topology and a natural measure
one way to think about topology is to
think about think about it in the light
language of Li groups so there's a
there's a canonical way of identifying
an element of this quotient of Li groups
with a lattice if you've not familiar
with it don't worry about it it's just
the space of all lattices equipped with
a nice topology and this is what
alluding to and on this space it was an
actual probability measure which is
constructed out of so called hard
measure for s Ln R and was constructed
by Zico so I'm calling it the Harz Eagle
measure no I called it the HAR measure
although I think that's the story on G
but this is the unique measure on this
space which is invariant under linear
transformations presumably there's only
one measure on the space of lattices
which is natural from a mathematical
point of view in that all quantities of
you measure R don't depend on the new
transformation so for example counting I
don't know any any random variable that
involves counting the number of points
in a ball will be the same as the same
random variable involving counting the
points in the lips of the same volume
because you can map the ball through so
in that sense it's a natural measure
okay so with respect to this measure it
was not known so let me write that as a
question question what is
l is a lattice it's chosen at random
with respect to this measure mu n and we
want to know how big this theta K can
behave can be and let me just remind you
that theta K has an obvious lower bound
of one with respect to this to this
measure its expectation is actually
infinite so you can have arbitrarily
large covering volumes and in fact you
can make large at a rate which is sort
of bigger than the measure the inverse
of the measure of a very very degenerate
lattices so in some sense the
expectation is not the correct quantity
to ask about but a specific question can
people see if I write down here so a
question on stromberg said for example
was UN probability let me just let me
use the terminology coming
let's go to does this 0 as n tends to
infinity okay so sorry
zero
so there's this there's I when I use
volumes everything rescales nicely so
the obvious lower bound is one when you
use the notion of a covering radius the
absolutely the lower bound is the choice
of the radius making the unit Euclidean
will have volume one which is
approximately square root of n and so
what's Robertson wanted to know is
whether the probability that you're far
away by a constant factor from the lower
bound whether that goes to zero as the
dimension increases and if you sort of
as I said covering radius quote problems
can be translated into covering density
problems if you sort of rearrange this
and think about the relation is he's
basically asking whether this
whether the volume grows X if you look
at a exponentially increasing rate of
growth of the volume does the measure of
lattices with that property go to zero
with the volume that was this question
and we can answer this affirmative me
and in fact we show that you can do much
much better so let me write down and
this is related to the previous question
about the measure so this is this from
from my point of view this would be the
natural measure with respect to which
well you should ask this question Rogers
was using a different manner which I
think is the reason it's just it's well
adapted to his method but I don't think
it's a natural measure in any sense
so let me write down our result I'll
write down a precise result and then on
about this problem and then I'll explain
for constants c1 c2 c3 c4 and total
convex bodies K in RN all numbers M
the regime this weird login cubed
probability over density so we're giving
you an upper bound on the probability
with respect to this measure that the
covering density is bigger than a
parameter M M is in the regime of ends
between N squared log in and then cubed
so corollary one
okay so if you're choosing random
lattices in high dimension and you're
looking at a complex body and the convex
body has volume approximately N squared
then you have very high probability of
hitting a lattice for which this covers
and if you want to be the next one sure
you might want this to go to zero
exponentially fast this probability and
then you should choose your volume to be
on the order thank you
yep so in terms of this Delta you're
saying that that they was 1 over N yeah
Delta equals 1 over N I have to do the
math to do because it's not it's not
even it's even more precise because I
have to distinguish in N squared and n
cubed right so 1 over N some people can
do these computations faster than I can
you know the concentration of the radius
has you know I didn't understand a
question
so it's defining are not by volume okay
wouldn't it be better to define it as a
draw of the ball you need to take to get
the covering radius to cover space plus
so like this for a random lattice I mean
I choose my are not just to be the
obvious lower bound so R naught is the R
naught is the simpler bound given by
volume on the covering volume
irrespective of the
okay so this is like usually called are
effective but the engineers call this
the are effective is the effective
ratings so the proof has involved a
couple of steps and a surprising thing
is as I told you we have an electrical
engineer on the team computer scientist
on the team and I'm dynamicists the new
tool comes from combinatorics which is a
field that none of us are experts in so
that's quite nice actually
so it's something called the discrete
kakeya problem so I'll tell you what the
discrete became problem is and I hope to
have enough time to really show you
basically the proof not of theorem - but
of theorem 1 so from here on out I'll
just give you our new proof or our proof
of theorem 1 and then if people ask
questions I can tell you more about what
is a kakeya set what is a discrete
kakeya set and I need that definition
about it discrete kakeya set of rank R
okay let's write everything down and
then oh so we're working in the finite
field F P P is a prime or it could be a
power and Prime and we're looking at a
substance set which has P to the N
elements and it's a vector space and so
this grass Manian is all the our
dimensional subspaces for starters just
think of art as being equal to one so
that if R is equal to one this is all
lines in this vector space and we're
saying that a set is called the discrete
kakeya set if it contains a translate
translated copy of each plane so in the
case of lines it contains a line in
every day in every direction and there's
been a lot of activity obviously the
bigger set is the more likely it is to
be a discrete kakeya set and so people
are interested in getting bounds on the
possible sizes of case that's what they
want to say that it is said easy care
said it can't be too small and there was
a big breakthrough regarding the size of
kakeya sets and associated mainly with
the name of de vere about ten years ago
but there's been a lot of subsequent
work and so I'm going to state a theorem
of you know that we need is not due to
fear it's due to KL SS which is co party
left sera from Sudan from 2011 and what
they proved
following we care about the case the
break to
and so they prove that the cardinality
of Coco set e to the minus n over P
times P to the N P to the N is the size
of the entire set and we're going to be
interested in the regime where P and n
are approximately the same so what this
is so this will come out to be a
constant so what they're saying is that
the decay instead of rank two should
occupy at least the constant proportion
the entire discreet vector space and let
me since I want to use it in a few
minutes of coffee I'll record a
corollary of this
if you have a set which is big enough so
that it's compliment cannot be Co K is
said if you have a set which is so large
that it's complement can't be kakeya set
that means that you can find a two
dimensional subspace so that no matter
how are you translated it has to
intersect that set in other words it
can't be contained in the confidence
okay so let's just keep this in mind and
just think about this in the case where
n is equal to P so this just becomes 1
over 1 over 1 minus 1 over e oh people
probably I'm going to end up not energy
oh it's 45 minutes - so I like yes thank
you longer thank the organizers for
inviting me
so second so that this is like let's
call this ingredient so for the proof
[Music]
this is the reason I'm highlighting this
ingredient is that it wasn't around when
Rogers was doing his work and the bounds
that were discussing had not been
approved since Roger so for around 50
years the next two ingredients that I
want to tell you about our ideas
basically which can be found in Rogers
so the second ingredient and the idea
here is that if you can cover if your
set is convex and it covers maybe not
the entire Euclidean space but it covers
a set which is dense grid then you can
slightly make it slightly larger and
then it will cover so they're the most
efficient way to state that is in terms
of the quotient lattices quotient
alright when you have a lattice in RN
you can divide by the lattice to get a
periodic set a torus and I'll state the
theorem in the language of tour I so we
have two lattices l1 and l2 l1 is
contained in l2 we have a convex body
okay in our head and we have positive
parameter row let me draw the diagram
are in that's the first torus which is
quotient of our end by one and this maps
further into the quotient of RN by L to
remember that L 1 is contained in L 2 so
we have this map of these two maps and
let's call this first map time - and we
make two assumptions the first is that
let me explain these two i policies let
me write down the conclusion first the
conclusion is that the lattice l1 will
give you a cover of space with your
convex set K as long as you inflate K by
a small factor we think of Rho as being
a small number okay so this is what you
want to achieve the way you so you're
trying to cover using l1 you should
think of l2 is giving you this set I to
inverse of X to 0 which is a some kind
of nice grid regular grid sitting inside
this torus okay so if I draw the picture
if this is the first torus I can take a
point in the quotient and pull it back
and I get a nice regular torus which is
the preimage of some point under this
and so the first assumption is that the
projection of K covers this discrete set
of points and the second assumption is
that the this set K projected all the
way down here measured with respect to
the natural probability measure there
are the lebesgue probability measure on
the downstairs torus occupies at least
half of space when you make these two
assumptions okay so this is a lot of
hard not a difficult fact which is due
to users
the next ingredient but you need you
need you know you need to wrote to be
big enough for this to happen
ah the row is there yes the third
ingredient is a difficult piece of work
done by Rogers and Wolfgang Schmidt in
the 50s and 60s so this is our name for
it and so let me state it so you have
again a lattice but we're going to be
varying the lattice so in a moment so L
is the lattice whenever I have a lattice
let's denote the quotient poorest are n
divided by L by T of L and and we have a
set which length we can call J a subset
of RN all it needs to be for this
theorem is measurable it doesn't matter
whether or not it's fixed and what we're
interested in is what happens when you
take this in RN and project it to this
torus TL and L varies and for different
L this projection is going to cover
either most or few a small part or a big
part of the quotient torus
this is imagining Lydian balls say of
volume 2 if you're taking Z 2 it's going
to probably cover everything but if
you're taking a lattice with a very
short vector and the lattice with a very
long vector there's a large open holes
inside and it's not going to cover much
and so this is a random variable so the
random variable is denoted by
epsilon in Rogers notation and okay so
one is the total area il MJ is what's
covered by the projection of J we're
measuring how much is covered by the
projection of J and then which this is a
this is the proportion of proportion of
the torus projection and they did over
here but I'll state the corollary over
there because it's not really crucial to
get
take a set V whose volume is growing
linearly with n at most and you take a
parameter Kappa then the measure with
respect to this natural measure the
lattices for which the amount you miss
is bigger than Kappa times e to the
minus the volume so let's look at this
so basically this is telling you that
the threat the threshold is e to the
minus V so think of you have a fixed set
J you're projecting it on to tour I for
a random torez and just think of this as
a kind of a completely independent event
for every point whether or not it's
going to be hit or missed by this
projection and if you sort of use that
heuristic you're sort of going to reach
the conclusion that most points are
going to be hidden the probability that
you're going to be missed is roughly e
to the minus V where V is the volume and
so what's the probability of going above
each of the minus V by a constant factor
Kappa its decaying with Kappa and
there's an additional term now if V is
close to the critical there's there's a
bound on V here V can't be very very
large your set has to be fairly small
okay so if he is close to being as the
maximal size allowed in the theorem then
this term starts becoming large but it's
a these constants a or growing smaller
than linearly an N then this term
becomes
irrelevant and the probability is going
to zero okay so it's this is a technical
statement which was quite hard to prove
and I think Rodgers was quite proud of
it you'll see and let me just state a
corollary here for later use so I'm
going to use it with V equal to two that
will equal to e probability that
probability that the amount that gets
missed is bigger than 1 over e is less a
little low so in other words for so we
take a set its volume is 2 which is
slightly bigger than 1 and we take a
large enough dimension then most points
in the in the sense that all but 1 over
e of points are going to get hit and I
chose this 1 over 8 because it matches
this 1 over 8
remember that P equals n ok so this 1
over E is going to be minus so now I've
set up all that I need in order to
sketch the proof of the
no lies this time how am i doing on time
okay so I'm going to sketch of proof of
theorem one so I'm trying to I'm trying
to show you why if you have a compact
set whose size is growing like N squared
or constant times N squared you can find
a lattice so that together they cover
all of space and I want to use the
discretization lemma so I'm going to try
to reach the conclusions of this
descritization level but I haven't
figured out yet what l1 and l2 are so I
forgot to let me keep the notation that
I have before there are two lattices in
the background l1 is contain an l2 and
I'm going to do this in two steps in the
first step I'm going to find a lattice
of ko volume 1 which is given to me by
Rogers so that the projection of my set
K onto the quotient occupies most of
space but definitely not all of space
and definitely not enough so it covers a
grid like this and then I'm going to
find another lattice bigger than it for
which it actually verified and that's
where ko ko will come in so okay and in
the statement I want to prove K's convex
set of volume n but I'm just going to
start with a convex set of volume 2 so
just think of your convex set and
rescale it so that has volume 2 for now
so let K the reason I chose 2 is because
that's what I wrote over there in the
second corollary so by this corollary
one by corollary - you're just a lotta
cell so that in other words the
projection of L on to the quotient the
projection of K on to the quotient of
space by L misses less than 1 over e of
space
let's take p to be a prime of course
it's a joke not all ends or primes but
we can take an N which is we can take a
prime which is close to N so say between
N and 2n or something like this it will
only affect constants so I'll just
assume that and its prime if you like
and think of the vector space the
discreet vector space F P to the N as
the projection one over P times L and
this pie is a projection and we divide
the lattice by P meaning we make it
smaller by 1 over P in each direction we
have and we project so we get we're
getting P to the N regularly spaced
points inside the lattice so this would
be like an example with P 5 or 7 so this
is a discreet net and it's not
necessarily satisfying this quantity
that missed it that it's get to be gets
that a complete translator now I'm
talking P 2 inverse of X 0 means you are
allowed to translate this around in the
torus
well let's translate it around so that
the number of points that get hit are
the average number of points that get
hit so there exists 0 0
[Music]
portion proportion of this
corollary one discrete kacang up
assumption I can find a two-dimensional
dimensional subspace / FP again where I
think of I think of this projection as a
copy of FP to the power N and in this F
P to the power n I apply the kakeya and
I can find a element of the
two-dimensional breast Manian which
intersects every line so now what I'm
going to do I haven't defined l1 yet now
the definition of l1 will be a thickened
L by adding s to it okay fine this is
some elements some sub subspace some two
dimensional subspace of elements in this
projection of this subsystem it's a
subgroup in this quotient group so I can
just add it to L and get a lattice and
the index of this lattice is exactly the
size of s which is P squared so valium
now if you think about what I've done
because of this because of this claim
what I've done is I've added points to
my lattice so that in every direction in
my lattice I'm going to now hit the
image of K at least once so that means
that when I project further into the
quotient by L then the set K is going to
satisfy this exactly this hypothesis
sorry l2 okay so if you think about this
for a moment you'll see that with these
choices both of these hypothesis
I thought to verify this hypothesis
which is the main hypothesis with these
choices this hypothesis will hold and so
will this hypothesis if I choose row to
be one over convince yourself that I
haven't lied to you and it just follows
from this choice of l1 okay and that's
sort of the punchline of the proof and
now what we're getting is this now k was
of koval um-- - i've made it larger by
just a constant factor but i have to
rescale everything by a factor of P
squared because that's the co volume of
l1 when I do that nothing happens to 2
over 2 times row is 1 over P so 1 over P
times rescale that P squares only
affects the volume up to a bounded
amount so I have come if I rescale the
picture you'll see the covered space by
a body which is a dilate of K and has a
volume constant
that's basically the proof do I have one
more minute or not sure so just one word
about the proof volume of theorem - so
theorem 2 is about this horse eagle
measure in order to prove theorem - you
have to run through the same steps and
check that what you're doing works for a
random choice of L and this is not a
random choice of ever used pacaya so we
have to upgrade ruqaiya
to something called epsilon kakeya sets
which is talking about most choices of
these essence of these subspaces s and
we also have to analyze this horsy go
measure and the point about hard Eagle
measure is that it has the following
property if you randomly choose a
lattice according to our Siegel measure
and then randomly choose a sub lattice
of a fixed index or a super lattice of a
fixed index in this case we chose l1 to
be a super lattice of if you make those
two that second choice uniformly you're
still working with the Harz legal
measure naturality property and so what
we have to do in order to prove the
second theorem is to sort of run through
the whole argument again with a souped
up version of the kakeya problem which
actually is our another one of our
contributions it wasn't in the
literature and this understanding of the
hard legal measure to get the
[Applause]
because I think up behavior or the upper
bound is for larger than so this is very
similar to what we do in information
theory and is asymptotic can you say
something about finite then we didn't I
mean I think the answer is yes so in our
constants are quite explicit and also
are Rogers constants if you reach was
just amazing how explicit they are super
so I believe the answer is yes one would
have to carefully track the constants
now you just need some numbers to be
bigger than other numbers and you know
that's true asymptotically so I don't
know when that will kick in I think it
will kick in not too large and so the
rank one key case statement is I mean of
course you're asking you're asking about
our frustration so let me tell you about
our frustration so definitely we wanted
very much to match Rogers and to reprove
Rogers and to framework and that would
men would have met their problem
dimension 1 and then dimension 1 we're
kind of off by constants so it's always
it's never nice to be
you never know where the mistake might
be lurking at the moment not only can we
can't be we have constant coming from
Rogers and they have the constants
coming from the experts we could improve
on Rogers constants literature they a
lot of their estimates are tight so the
answer is thinking about it but we don't
have an answer at the moment I guess
it's an interesting problem as to
whether they need the truth is close
with the end I can't spin him in and the
constant is wait so where does the N
squared finally come from that no we've
dilated by by P and so so l1 so we had a
clue that the the volume of the said K
was a constant but then we dilated the
picture using the co volume of marijuana
which is just P squared because for L it
was 1 and then we added a 2 dimensional
we added P squared number of points so
now it becomes P squared which is
essentially in splitting our realization
yeah so I guess you could of course my
buddy chain right so lambda n is I'm
sorry no Amanda the only thing I could
say which might be useful information is
that this legal our measure is invariant
under taking duals right so if you have
some set of large volumes and so and so
is the set of duals so wait so which is
lambda 1 is connected to so I don't know
but people have studied the behavior the
first step for six games came the new
institution of them that K is pretty
much sure but not further there's been
some literature on the regime
[Applause]